hey everyone welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're gonna
keep coding our search page and we
already have the search working with the
WordPress API so we type in the search
box and whatever we type get saved into
state because we're using react and then
state updates the input and every time
the input changes it fires off a
function that searches sends off a
search query to the WordPress API that
data comes back and then populates our
page now what we want to do is take some
of those check boxes that we added
yesterday I'm going to connect those to
the state and we're going to use the
value in state to change our parameters
in our query that we're sending to the
WordPress API so that a user wouldn't
just search for one word throughout all
our data they would search for a word
and be able to say I want to search for
just this word in just this type of
content so they'll be able to narrow
down their search a lot more and it'll
have the added benefit as well to be a
little bit easier on the wordpress api
and not having to search through so many
different types of data because
everything split out into custom post
types so on our end of things we sent
one query but really on the wordpress
and it needs to make separate searches
as far as I understand from the way it
works in the PHP is that separate search
does happen for each of those post types
so all around I think it'll be a better
user experience and it'll cut down on
what needs to happen
in WordPress to get that data out to us
so that's the plan for today
all right cool looks like from the
stream analytics we have a decent number
of viewers so I'm gonna put the link to
what we're working on in a live chat now
and I may put it in again later if we
get some more users I don't want anyone
to miss out so the link that I just put
into the live chat will connect you up
with what I'm running locally so we're
using a service called
end Rock and the creator of Angra as
generously allowed free code kept in
this stream to use an unlimited version
of end Rock for free which is awesome
I'm not even sure that you can buy an
unlimited version
I think the plans all have limits so
really awesome of him to to donate that
for us and it allows the stream to be a
lot more interactive so you can check
the site open it up in dev tools every
time I make a change locally you will be
able to see the change immediately in
your browser you're not limited to
seeing just the page that I have on the
screen you can you look around in the
site and you do whatever you like so let
me Oh before we start I want to tell you
just a little story so please be patient
with me and humor me for a second while
I tell you the story I forgot to say
yesterday but yesterday I was in a
coffee shop so I spent the morning
working in a new coffee shop that just
opened yesterday morning and it's very
close to where I work so it's it's a
little bit far to walk it's down a hill
and
across the street and stuff but driving
distance it's you know less than a
minute so anyway I go in there and I'm
working on my laptop so I'm a laptop
with all the dev stickers and everything
on it and I'm working and then I noticed
somebody's looking at me and so I look
over there and they come come over and
say are you Jesse
I say yeah and they said I watched your
stream I watched your coding stuff and
it was just like the weirdest like
coolest thing I have never had anybody
recognize me from the stream before and
I don't know it was really awesome so so
I talked to him for a while and it turns
out he's a computer science major here
at the university that I work for and
I've never met him before so he actually
knows some of the same students in the
computer science program and you know
he's been watching my show and I had no
idea so I got a picture with him and we
exchanged emails and I invited him to
come over and be on the show if he wants
to or he'll come to my office and show
me what he's working on or ask me
questions or anything so anyway I that
was just a really amazing experience for
me so I just wanted to share that with
you all if any of you ever do happen to
see me don't hesitate to come up and
talk to me I'm really friendly and um so
I won't you won't bother me like I won't
be freaked out just you know say hi I'll
be super happy if you say hi so I know
if any of you are in the Pittsburgh area
like it's possible you might see me cuz
I I am also in the Pittsburgh area and I
just said somebody asked me about my dev
sticker so I'm gonna show my laptop
quickly I have it here so here my
stickers
so I have some this is a Windows 95
sticker and I found this one on a window
when they were doing construction on my
building
and somebody had just left it there so
it was essentially probably going to be
taken out with the window and thrown
away so I made sure I grabbed that and
it's held on with scotch tape out of
some from November conference syntax con
hacked ogre fest so all of them are tech
related except for this one or this one
is just the earth Vader one my
brother-in-law got me that for Christmas
and then this is a window sticker and I
took off the Microsoft because it was
huge and just kept these so anyway those
are my laptop stickers right now have a
little bit of space left to put some
some more on there and oh cool so if
Peter says the Darth Vader was cool yeah
I actually have I have some other ones I
just didn't really have a spot to put
them so they might end up going on
another laptop or I don't know what I'm
gonna do with them for sure but I have
Boba Fett and this skull I have a
stormtrooper and kylo Ren the awesome
cool was and I have some other ones like
natla Phi and like get get crackin so I
just have some other ones usually I I
only like to put stickers on my laptop
for things that I actually use so some
of the ones that aren't on there yet are
products that I don't really use some of
them I do want to try to use at some
point so they might get on that
so all Michael says sign them and send
them to people oh that's a cool idea I
never thought anybody would want
anything
signed by me but then that's actually
not a bad idea I'm still not sure people
would want him sign they might just want
the stickers but yeah officer think
about that all yeah maybe I'll think
about me what the best way to do that
would be and then I'll get this I also
have some free code camp stickers at my
house all right so I better get started
I want one more comment I'm gonna read
out before we get started from Tracy
says hi Jesse thanks for the live coding
stream you're welcome thanks for
watching I'm just looking for my post
PHP heavy development environment just
wondering and learning thanks to free
code camp and generous coders like you
what all this is about oh thank you for
saying that that's that's awesome
and Tracy any questions you have let me
know either in the chat live or comments
or on Twitter or via wherever okay cool
also asks what's at stake well Stephen
got a job all right Stephen
congratulations
so Stephen got a job starting next
Monday really really cool I'm super
happy for you
yeah so let as much as you're
comfortable with let us know about the
job and how everything goes I definitely
love to hear from you I totally
understand if you can't be around for
the live chat as much you know your new
job might keep you busy but if you can
check in and just say hello and let us
know how it's going now that would be
great
all right awesome I love when I hear
stuff like that really really happy for
you okay all right let's get started so
I actually I have a meeting at 3:00 p.m.
my time it
is not 142 p.m. so he can't be super
long on the stream I still want to try
to get to Pomodoro sessions in if I can
alright Steven says senior web developer
/ designer for API and JavaScript
awesome
awesome that's really cool you got the
steam your web dev in there - that's
really really cool yeah so cool really
happy for you
all right so let me all right we have a
bunch of people now in the chat so I'm
not gonna keep you all waiting any
longer let me switch the screens you
have something better to look at in my
face and start the Pomodoro timer and
get back to here I was like working on
the server I don't have that committed
yet to github but it's just very minor
work and just some comments so we're
gonna be working on the search the
search page and I did do a few changes
to the search page and pretty much all I
did was change the text on the page so
it's not completely up to date on github
yet but there's nothing major that's
changed just just the text okay I see
you me to share the link to the Pomodoro
timer I will share that I think this is
the one that harsh it built so one of
our viewers built this Pomodoro timer
and so we're using that as I know
several of you have built Pomodoro
timers if anybody builds Pomodoro timer
and wants me to use it on the show let
me know send me a link to it or
something and I can rotate and just kind
of use a different one every time okay
so let me go down let's make some space
let's get rid of that and let's move
this over here we don't really need this
terminal right now there we are okay
so we have a separate page that's a
component a react component for our
search page if you want to see it just
type in slash search at the end of that
and grok link and I ought to put that in
the live chat one more time since we do
have a lot of new people that weren't
here when I put it in before so this end
rock link after the dot IO put slash
search and you can see what page we'll
be working on so you can see I just
changed the labels so I didn't even
change the the values or you know
anything like that yet so I need to go
in and change that first and then we can
actually start testing this out the
search I don't think works right now so
I think when I added these check boxes
in I broke something so it may not work
close asked about are we using WordPress
with nodejs I thought it was only PHP
we're getting data from WordPress and
we're pulling it in to react that we're
running with node so we're using both
but the WordPress is now it's hosted I
think I have a test WordPress site on
GoDaddy I think yeah I don't think I
made a droplet for it eventually it'll
be on its own digitalocean droplet we
might deal with AWS I haven't decided
for sure yet so let's make this majors
and I did have some i sat down with my
boss today and decided some things about
design on some of the pages so we may
have some new stuff going on with design
departments and this faculty so some of
the interior pages are gonna have a
little bit more involved like fancier
design you know bit more elements on the
page so we'll probably be working on
that sometime soon and I had another
presentation of this website today which
which went well so had some good
questions to kind of like think about up
you know opportunities and possibilities
for the site okay I had put news in here
but we're gonna change this up to match
what we just said so what we had faculty
majors was the other departments
departments major and I need to make
that singular I believe so let's keep
them the same here oops
Department I'd like I'd like to keep it
all singular
I don't know why I made that plural it
doesn't really even make sense as a
plural label okay
so let me save that and then I'm gonna
show you what it looks like now on the
search page I can find it there we are
so I was on the theology page I see the
the logo didn't load oh there we are I
don't know what happened there but let's
move this to the Search Search page I
also have an idea for how to change the
router I think it'll make the router a
little bit faster and it'll give us more
freedom to do things with the route so
I'm not gonna change that much on it but
I think the change will be good so I
might do that on a different stream or
maybe after I do the change I'll just
show what happened on the next stream
after that and let's see if you are
asking questions in the live chat I'm
not ignoring you I'm just going to get
to the questions once this Pomodoro
timer gets down to zero and then I'll
take a few minutes and and catch up with
the live chat okay so here's what we
have now we have our search input what
I'd like to user to be able to do once
they search is also to click one or more
of these checkboxes and then it'll say
you know they let's say they only want
to search for faculty members then they
just check faculty and they type in
their search and they'll only get
results that are faculty members you
know so or any combination of these so
what we'll definitely have more
checkboxes than just this and what also
at some point have a sorting feature as
well that'll might be the next thing
that we add in so that you know maybe
they can sort the pages by newest or
alphabetically or you know however else
we can think of to sort them we want to
give we want to give the users the most
freedom and control of their searches as
we can reasonably give them
so let's actually let me see if this is
working whoa
yeah not working all right so I'm sure
as we go through hoops as we go through
and connect these check boxes up to our
search function we'll find the mistake
hopefully okay so we already have our
our on change functions connected and
it's gonna pass this value okay which is
great and this value will match up with
the key that we have in state so with
state we have these check boxes and
they're split up see how they be split
up right now we have an array of objects
I'm gonna leave it like that just for
now but I don't think we need to have an
array of objects I think we can clean
that up a little bit but I really like
to just get this working so I want to
you know maybe try to go as fast as I
can through this let's see so in our
search term but our fetch search term
function we have this state search type
okay that needs to go on to this this
URL so the search term is going to tell
WordPress what to search for but then
these search types are going to tell it
which post types to actually do the
search in so we need to create this as a
string so what we can do is make this
let's see let
how are we gonna do this search hell
okay sorry so work making in state we
have search type so sorry about that
I was in the wrong function I had
forgotten that we made this in the state
so let's we want to go to the function
where we're actually clicking on the
check box and that is handle change I
believe yep okay so when we handle the
change we're saying this set states and
then whatever the name is and then we're
making it the value checked so this is
how we pulled this in from the component
demo and the material UI documentation
we may need to change this let me think
so we certainly don't want the values to
be c-word like this is state name check
again we're gonna have to switch it up
so just to show you what's happening now
let's check this out and let's go into
the react dev tools
so let me was I search don't we have a
search component I guess not
all right so here's our state so we have
our check boxes array but when you
actually click a check box you see it
adds faculty right so it's still doing
what it was going in the material UI
documentation so it's not even at all
you're taking into account what we've
created in state so let's switch this up
a bit I think so
we need to keep this sort of thing here
but I would rather have I would rather
have this in the check boxes array and
as long as we keep the the names of the
check boxes the same as what we actually
have to search for or the name we
actually have to put in the query I
think this will work because we can just
grab we can grab the keys and use those
so let's try that out
so if we were to do this it needs to be
States in
nor did we call that our checkboxes
all right how are we gonna do this
checkboxes not sure if this will work
I'm gonna try like this first not sure
if it'll work but let's let's give it a
shot I'm also going to remove I'm gonna
remove all of this and just that instead
alright so let's see if it works all
right cool
no knuckle so it's not yes we don't want
that we want let's see
oops the state let's try that so what
we'll do here is we're combining these
so these three dots I believe that's the
spread operator correctly with them long
sometimes I I forget the terminology but
this is gonna allow us just to combine
these two things so that before it was
over writing this now it's gonna combine
it let's let's test it out make sure
that's right
okay mmm not working well let me refresh
completely here and see what's happening
Varia search okay so let's check out
checkboxes there's nothing right now if
we click faculty there we are in
Department no no no okay it's not
working now
who did I do
all right let me see what I've done let
me check the live chat chat first to see
if you all have caught my mistake since
you all usually catch my mistakes before
I do let's see Nicki says initialize
every checkbox value in state okay so I
should initialize all the values first
then in state let's see
Stephen says it's not resetting that
state when unselected
alright well let's let's put in the
values and see if that does anything so
we're gonna initialize these values here
and state what I wanted to do so what
did we add Department
let's do major faculty
okay so now we have him initialized and
stayed
okay
let's see Nicki sang use the pre state
version of getting state I probably
should just check the get up repo for
the catechetical Institute site that we
did the same thing in and see how we did
it there that would probably save us a
lot of time so let's let's check that
out and see I react
let's see pages resources okay so where
we handling
as we
all right I have a better repo let's
look at that resource center repo
because we were using material you I
hear so I don't think I don't think we
were doing it the best way for the
catechetical Institute site since we
were mixing in materialized CSS
components
is a form
those views
alright so in our service request form
this cause checkboxes
and Oh input change
you okay
I'm checking live chat again to see some
more things he says you are already
using it a bunch set state okay objects
okay Nikki yeah let me try I'll try that
out before we implement some of this
before I try to implement some of that
do we have okay
here we are
Oh what am I getting here
which Nicki's saying another closing
parenthesis you ever an existing one
didn't had a new one
oh okay your thanks cool totally didn't
see that my my timer is going off for
this formative hour session so I'm going
to take a break answer some questions on
the live chat and then come back to this
and see if we can sort out what we need
to do here so we have done this two
different ways in previous projects
this project is slightly different but
I'm sure we can figure this out
by adapting what we've done previously
if we have to all right it's this
five-minute timer I'm gonna scroll up to
the top so I don't miss any questions
and I'm just going to go down through
whatever was asked first that's what
I'll get to first hopefully I can get to
everything before I have to end this
dream hey everyone see a lot a lot of
people saying hello so I'm just gonna
say hi to everyone that said hi there at
the beginning of the chat
so Huff's going down there are no
questions so far
or I've already addressed them all
Michael says Jessie your kids grow up so
fast
they do grow up so fast but I'm not sure
like where did that come from in the
middle of the decoding but that is
definitely true Shrikant says you're
doing great you deserve some
appreciation Jessie thank you thank you
trying to do a good job and to be honest
with you most people are appreciative of
the work I do so occasionally there are
some people that aren't so appreciative
but they're in the minority of people I
I usually hear positive comments so it's
been really nice say sore ass is this
really advanced I'm not sure it doesn't
seem that advanced for me but like we've
gradually been building up to this so it
probably seems like a lot right now like
just coming into the project but I guess
kind of keep in mind that like we've
built up to this little by little so I
mean you definitely you know it's not
it's not a project that would give to a
beginner for sure but the building
blocks to get here you know or sometimes
you know just very simple things it's
just we combine them and in you know
build on them and then we end up with I
don't know what I think is turning out
to be a pretty nice site I'm after
google translate this next question
let's detect language
so we have a question that says your
movements are correct the applications
you're doing are not right so that was I
think that that statement came around
the time when I was trying to do the
checkbox stuff so yeah so I guess that's
that was true yeah I am messing
something up here it is here and it says
hey hey how's it going thanks for
watching Chris says using very a virtual
dorm with react and es6 looks pretty
awesome it is pretty awesome it's really
fun i I think reactive is super fun
you Ilia I think that's how you
pronounce it let me know if it's not but
Ilyas is could you describe your
computer setup okay so my setup right
now is I have an iMac and it has I'm
running like 32 gigs of ram it has the
27-inch 4k screen on the main screen or
sorry 5k screen on the main screen
I'm running a the secondary 2k 27-inch
monitor
I think there's I think it's 27 and then
as another screen I have a vertical
display that's just an old Lenovo
widescreen monitor but it's it's just
vertical and that's kind of good for
longer articles and things like that
sometimes I put dev tools over there and
so that's my set up right now I have an
external microphone set up so it's
better audio for the streams which I
think I used the keyboard that comes
with with a Mac and like the trackpad
thing that comes with a Mac so that's
that's my setup I don't remember I guess
I could tell you real quick if I go to
about this computer I could tell you
what the specs are I'm am using Visual
Studio code for my editor and my
terminal was I term to about this Mac
let's see yeah okay so they are 27-inch
displays the retina 5k it's the late
2014 model iMac 4 gigahertz Intel Core
i7
and AMD Radeon r9 - gigabyte graphics
card yep and not that it matters that
much but I'm running the one terabyte
hard drive I believe it's the SSD but I
can't be sure I don't remember for sure
Wow that lenovo display is it's 21.5
inch and it is in 1080p crazy I did not
realize that it just doesn't look that
good compared to the right next to the
5k screen so all right so let me go back
do another Pomodoro session and then
anything that I've missed in the live
chat I'm going to answer after this next
pompadour session I need it right down
where I left off in the chat that's okay
I need to keep an eye on the time so I'm
not late for my next meeting
all right it looks like there were a few
other things in the in the chat about
our the issue that I'm having right now
so let me check those Christophe I see
that your suggestion
okay Nietzsche says we don't need an
updated function if we're using the
material UI checkbox
all right great Christophe I think you
what you put in there it's gonna work
yeah yeah that looks good
let me change this up to do that as well
so we won check we're going to take name
and put it here and then we'll do
[Music]
checked yeah we're not gonna need whoops
yeah I'm gonna take a lot of this out
take that out
oops and I need a this said state
checkboxes
lemme see even checked you know sheets
okay
and we don't
okay there we are right no all right
and I don't need that okay now it's
checkbox this is still giving me trouble
[Music]
lexical chuckles engine chokes [ __ ]
I mean I'm looking at this it looks like
it should work
I see the mean let me go back to what we
originally had that I know worked I
don't want to let's see I don't want to
go that for pay so I'm gonna miss out on
that let's just let me just grab from
material UI what we did have if I can
find it I have a lot of stuff up all my
screens right now
here we go all right so let me grab that
handle change
okay so we did have four handle change
so let's just put checkboxes name handle
change alright so we are still getting
the same stuff going on here
you want to verify that yes we are still
getting the air okay let me check back
in the live chat
okay Nikki saying what we did that
before almost words we just needed to
spread inside the checkboxes section on
the state then add the update
okay
actually oh let me let me look back one
more time to it how we did it here where
we really putting so we okay so we were
doing this in this state with inform we
were putting all our check box stuff
inside form so when we went to handle
the input change let's just ignore all
the stuff that's not about check boxes
so if it was a check box
we're just saying checked so the value
is checked would on form name value
checked so this state form okay all
right this makes a lot more sense so
what we're doing here is getting that
whole object that is formed which in our
case will be check boxes
we're getting that object we are
changing the object and then we're
setting the state of that object that
makes sense
let's do that
so let's go misty for checkboxes whoops
let checkboxes equal this states check
boxes oops
check boxes and then we're gonna do this
check boxes
name equals checked and then we're gonna
do this set state equals good state
check boxes those check boxes all right
let me see if this works and then if it
does I'll explain what I've done but no
sense in telling you the wrong thing if
this doesn't work okay so do we have now
or not I want to be able to see the
state make sure we're doing the right
thing
is that not it okay here we are
so we're in checkboxes no it's still
creating one outside of here why do we
have doubled okay so it is doing what we
want but it's also doing something else
where is this where's this part
happening
all right so what I'm trying to do in
here and let me know in the live chat if
if I'm messing this up somehow
but basically is we're getting what the
current value of check boxes is right
with checks boxes is a now an object
that contains key value pairs
representing each check box the name is
the key the value is true or false
depending on whether it's checked or not
so we're taking that we're modifying it
and then we're combining it with this
but do we need to combine it with that
because we're not
yeah we're not getting rid of this so I
don't maybe we don't need to maybe we
can just do this
maybe that's suros I don't know if
that's what I was messing up but it was
unnecessary let's double check and make
sure it was unnecessary
you may give it a refresher
we need to remember what this is called
where can I go like here
every page okay
all right let's check it out a faculty
there we go okay and I see I'm sure some
of you in the live chat recognized my
error first so thank you for that okay
so this works now so let me explain
what's going on right now especially for
those of you who might not be familiar
with react I want to try to explain as
much as I can so basically the same
thing as I explain what's happening
before but now instead of trying to
combine what was there which was an
unnecessary step we're just setting
state to this new value for the check
boxes array I'm sorry the check boxes
objects so this check boxes object here
starts out with all the values being
false we go down to here let's assume we
just check a check box let's just say we
check the box for faculty so it would
pass the name faculty it would pass the
event and then it would pass the value
of checked which in this case the value
of check then becomes true so in the
check boxes object we're passing the
name so we're going to get the check box
item with the key value of faculty and
we're going to set its value to true
right because that's what the value of
checked is now then we're going to do
the set state and we're going to set or
in our state the check boxes object that
we've now updated we're sending that
whole object there again and that's
what's going to update state so let's
see so nikki says that way works but can
cause asynchronous
shoes.i
so in what way can it cause issues I'm
not denying that it causes issues I just
I'm not aware of them so I guess what
what issues does it cause and are these
issues that we need to be careful of in
this use case because if the issues
aren't going to affect us in this use
case I'm okay with leaving it like this
even if it may not be the best way just
for the sake of getting it done and
moving on Nietzsche says 'set State is
asynchronous okay so so Nico you trying
to say then that okay so set state here
so potentially our search could run
before set state and then it wouldn't
have the right criteria
I'm not I'm not sure if that's what
you're saying so let me know if that's
the case let's see I'm gonna continue on
just to see if we can make this work I
do need to check my time with 9 ok
almost 10 minutes so at this point let's
get
and see Nietzsche says the value and
state can run one behind checkbox so you
check it and it actually sets the state
to false you uncheck it and it goes to
true okay
all right let's so how would I test that
just click these a bunch of times really
fast or it's the better way to test this
okay Nietzsche says it seems to be
working well we just will have to keep
that in mind and then maybe once we get
it all working with more checkboxes and
things just check it again just to be
sure
all right so for now we need a way to
get this search type to make it a string
that we can put in here so let's that's
certain let me think where should we
make this
I'm gonna make it a separate function
right now I'm not sure that it needs to
be but at least it'll it'll be more
obvious what's happening to make a
separate function so we're gonna say
creates type okay not the best name in
the world but it'll work create search
types for now let's just put that in
there and put that in there so thanks
two stream equal
I want to do this
tag is this so string equals so string
it's just gonna be
you
all right so what's the best way to look
through an object this always gets me
woody what's the best for arrays and
what's the best for objects I always
forget
so we don't want to use map on objects
right but we can do we can do this right
did we do this wrong so she's safe
that's it object values yes I knew it
Thank You Nikki I knew that there is a
way to still use map with that that's
what I was looking at the other project
for I don't think we did any other
project though okay so we're gonna you
do object values state checkboxes the
map and we're gonna do
okay key-value
oops
we're gonna do if if value then search
string equals
[Music]
can I not do an if statement and I can't
just return into statements I need to
change this up no I can't
okay let me and I can take ya this
shouldn't be there right yeah this one
shouldn't be there but this one should
be there
they
okay let me change the cue okay Nikki I
just saw that that message should let me
switch this up here okay
object entries okay object entries all
right thank you and was that actually
what we're using no we still were using
it there where did we use that at I know
we use it as at a project at some point
object entries yeah so we definitely
need both okay so let me go through let
me go through this just to explain what
we're doing so we're taking this object
and we're basically alright so this
we're treating this object as if it were
an array okay so that lets us map over
it we're getting the key value pairs and
then we're checking to see if the value
is true which means the box is checked
we're adding to the search string a the
end type and then we're putting that
name of key so it'll search through
everything here and create a string
that's going to have all the values that
we need to pass in here for our search
types so that's the idea and then what
we what we need to do though is set
state so this set States
Oh search string and this needs to be is
that what we called it actually if we
call it a search string then we're okay
now we call it search type didn't we
okay Search Search type
so string whoops and let's do this let's
do this here I don't think this is the
best place to put it but let's do this
here so we can see it building it every
time that we we check this so
all right so my timer is up and I do
have a meeting very soon
so I just want to test this out briefly
where we can look at state
yeah okay so the search term or search
type is what should be changing when we
do this there we go we should get
awesome okay check this out let me make
it a little bigger well that's really
big okay but hopefully you can see it so
what happened here so we checked both
these boxes faculty and Department so
now we have four search type of string
that's an type Department and type
faculty and that's exactly what we need
to pass in and so that that should work
so unfortunately I don't have enough
time to actually test this with a real
search so I have to stop here but is
creating the string as we want it so we
did test the search with a string that
was very similar to this and it worked
so assuming I mean really it should work
so should work isn't the same as does
work but it's looking good so far let me
scroll up to where we left off at and
try to get through all these questions
this is going to be a close one I'm
gonna do my best to get through the
questions but if I don't get through
them all I'm apologizing now and you can
we ask the question in the comments or
you know send me a message on some
social media platform or wait till the
next stream Steven asks about what what
is next J s next J s is very similar to
create react app if you're familiar with
that it just builds out a lot of the
like boilerplate react stuff that you
need it automatically has a webpack
config the thing that I like about next
J's is it comes with a basic router that
lets you just create routes by putting
components in a folder called pages
and then it also comes built-in with
server-side rendering so that's why we
chose next for this project instead of
create react app basically for the
server-side rendering Chad says hello
hey Chad thanks for watching Chris says
which type of projects would warrant
using reactive or other frameworks is it
when you are handling state yeah if you
need to handle state
I think react is is a good choice so if
you're building just like a one page
website you don't really need react you
could definitely use your act if you
wanted to I'd built really basic things
with react you know mainly for practice
but if you were building more of a web
app where you would have you know things
changing if you want kind of like an
easy way to handle client-side routing
in your web app using like react with
something like react router just makes
it so much easier than trying to create
your own routing system whether in
vanilla J s or jQuery or something like
that so that's when I would use it react
isn't the only option though there are a
lot of people using view for that same
sort of thing
some people prefer something like
angular so that's what I would use it
for there's definitely like a blurry
line as to like well when do I need a
framework and when do I not need a
framework and so you're gonna find
different answers to that question
depending on what article you read or
what video you watch so I generally say
if you want to learn a framework do a
really basic project even if it seems
like overkill because you'll get
practice you know don't try to tackle
some huge thing first if you're just
trying to learn later on you know then
you you get a hang
of what it could do and then you know
when that particular framework is going
to be useful or when it'll just be more
than you need
okay sakshum said the words are a little
small please zoom a bit okay hopefully I
did make things bigger in devtool so I'm
hoping that it did help you out sorry
about that
Nino has is there a method in react that
gets called when you set the state and
use the class component that it's called
component didn't mount yes there is a
component did mount so anything inside
component did mount will run when the
component has melted right just like it
says and there are other those are
called lifecycle methods so if you type
in react lifecycle methods you should
get as one of the search results a list
of all the different lifecycle methods
that are available so there's like
component will mount component did mount
those are the two that I've mainly used
there are others I can't remember myself
in my head right now but yes there they
are very helpful
Oh Annie key says I'm not routing very
interested to hear also please feedback
on PR from a weekly loop or request
uh-huh
I'm sorry Nikki I just I totally forgot
about that I will take a look at that PR
before I make changes to the routing I
wish I had time right now to explain
more to you I'll have to explain on
tomorrow stream or something like that
but the changes I want to make I think
they should fit in pretty easily with
what's already there with just like very
very minimal changes so hopefully we can
integrate your changes from that PR and
you know maybe my changes if they're
even needed and we can make it do a one
basically there's just a lot more
complexity to the URL structure as I
keep digging into it that I'm finding so
I was just had thought up a way to deal
with that complexity and in kind of a
different way and let us handle it and
still keep things the look of it kind of
simple and easy to figure out what's
going on as much as we can alright thank
you so much everyone for watching and
for all the help you all helped me so
much in the stream today I definitely
appreciate it
all one more question is that sublime
sex no this is Visual Studio code okay
alright so I really do I have to go and
and get to another meeting I should be
back tomorrow for another stream we'll
probably be working on this again or
maybe the router we'll see let's see Oh
Nikki neat Nikki I see that comment
that's exactly what I was thinking of
doing so I'm definitely gonna look at
your code I can't believe all right I
can't believe you both out of this we
both thought of the same solution I mean
you
thought of it a week before I did but I
should have just looked at that pull
request alright I would definitely check
it out and I may not even need to do
what I was thinking of doing I could
probably just do what you did mmm
sorry about that all right I'll be back
tomorrow thank you for watching thank
you for all your help you all are
awesome and until tomorrow have a
wonderful day